chrissy teigen nearly suffers the most  stylish wardrobe malfunction we've ever  seen I know the 31 year old model was  spotted at LAX Thursday with husband  John Legend and daughter Luna looking  like a million bucks before catching a  flight the lip sync battle host sported  golden aviators satin pants a designer  carry-on bag and a gorgeous Gucci  cardigan worth a whopping six thousand  dollars for some reason the airport is  so important to me and I just think  people should really dress up for the  airport Christie definitely turned heads  in her airport chic look unfortunately  one side of her top kept falling off her  shoulder and she narrowly missed a nip  flip it's ridiculous  [Music]